hey this is presh talwalkar
the green dots appear to be moving as a
circle
gently rolling inside of the larger blue
circle
but what you're seeing is actually not
true
this is an optical illusion
there are two parts to this puzzle
first
can you figure out what the true path of
each dot is and second can you prove why
this illusion happens
give it some thought and when you're
ready keep watching the rest of the
video for the mathematical explanation
to the circular motion illusion
so part one of the puzzle
is that the true path of each dot is a
straight line
if you follow any particular green dot
you'll see it's following exactly a
straight line segment and going back and
forth me present this to you in another
way so that it's easier to follow
i'll give each dot a different color
and now i will set the dots along
straight line segments
going back and forth
together all the dots appear like
they're moving like a circle that's
rolling around
and in fact when i remove the lines
it does appear like we have a circle
that's rolling inside of the larger
circle
but i will set colors to each of the
dots paths
and you'll see that each dot
is moving along a diameter of the larger
circle
each dot is actually only moving in a
straight line segment
and yet together
all of the dots are creating a circular
motion
so we know that each dot is moving in a
straight line but now the bigger
question is why does this happen what's
the geometrical explanation
let's get into the details
we'll start out with a circle that has a
radius r
and we have a smaller circle that's half
of its radius
let's let this circle roll inside the
larger circle
we're going to keep track of where the
green dot
goes in the smaller circle
follow the path of this green dot
if you see the path it traces out it's
exactly a straight line segment that's
the diameter of the larger circle
so this is good for illustration
purposes
but now we need to prove mathematically
that this happens and that it happens
for every single point in the smaller
circle
this is known as copernicus's theorem
if a small circle with radius r over 2
is perfectly rolling in a large circle
with radius r
a point on the smaller circle
circumference traces out a straight line
segment exactly equal to the larger
circle's diameter
so we have a large circle with the
center point o
we'll consider a smaller circle that has
half of its radius
we're going to trace where this point p
in the smaller circle traces out
so we have this smaller circle and we
can imagine letting it roll for a little
bit
so we now need to see where is this new
green point
so we have the circle where the circle
has rolled to
and this p prime is the new location of
p
we'll denote m as the point at which the
small circle now contacts the large
circle
so what we want to prove is we want to
prove that p prime and p are on the same
straight line diameter of the large
circle
and an alternate way of saying that is
we want to prove the angles m o p prime
and m o p are equal this will imply that
the point p prime is on the large
circle's diameter now as i've drawn it
it looks like they're all on the same
line because that is the case but we
don't actually know that so we're going
to have to prove that
so here are the steps to doing that
so the first part is that because point
p moves to p prime
the arcs mp
and mp prime have the same length
next since the small circle's radius is
half of the large circle's radius
the angle size of arc m p prime
is double that of arc m p
furthermore since angle mop prime is an
inscribed angle in the small circle it
has half the measure
of the angle size of the arc mp prime
so we put all this together and we're
going to get the following series of
equations
we have the angle mop prime
which is equal to half the angle size of
the arc mp prime that's by the inscribed
angle theorem
next we have the angle size of mp prime
is equal to two times the angle size of
mp the arc this is because we have the
small circle
subtending
an arc of the same length as the largest
circle with twice the radius
next we have the arc
mp is equal to the angle mop
that's because mop is a central angle of
the circle
and then we have the one half and the
two cancel out so we end up with the
last equation that's equal to angle mop
therefore we've shown that angles mop
prime and mop are equal to each other
and that's what we wanted to prove
this means point p prime is on the
diameter of the larger circle
so this proof by the way will work once
you get up to either 90 degrees
clockwise or counterclockwise rotation
when you need to go beyond that you
could just imagine that you do the same
proof except it's all reflected across
so it's the other point p double prime
on the other side of the diameter
so this shows that when you have a point
on this small circle
and you trace it out along this rolling
in the largest circle it will always be
along the diameter of the larger circle
did you figure out the illusion and then
did you know why it works
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preschool walker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description